un stade c'est d'abord remettre l'argent
parce que quand je regarde des autres
grandes priorités
c'est entre autres de commencer les
négociations que les deux fédérations de
médecins faut être réaliste cela sera
propice à se reproduire pas de résultat
dans les cinq premiers jo ça promet
d'espoir on assistera peut-être un
changement de ton et portant experts de
la santé et des services sociaux avec
l'arrivée de madame danièle ricard c'est
un nouveau visage en politique mais pas
dans le réseau de la santé puisqu'elles
étaient jusqu'à tours jusqu'à il ya deux
ans le pdg de l' agence de la santé et
des services sociaux de montréal et puis
travailleuse sociale de formation mais
plusieurs diplômes universitaires dont
vous avez fait pour votre vie dans cet
univers-là semaine univers qui vous est
inconnu madame est bienvenue
félicitations alors je vais beaucoup
interview docteur barrette au cours des
quatre dernières années et cela porte
essentiellement sur ce qui allait se
passer avec notamment les médecins
venaient d'entendre monsieur legault
comment vous avez voulu soulager deux
est obligé de faire sur liberty en 100
jours
mais je pense que monsieur legault notre
premier ministre est réaliste et mais
c'est certain que nous allons nous
mettre à la tâche alors ne nous mettons
à la tard j'aimerais parler au présent
parce que nous sommes au lendemain de
l'assermentation et nous nous mettons à
la tâche dès aujourd'hui prendre
connaissance des dossiers rapidement à
quelques jours et évidemment entamé des
rencontres importantes dans le dossier
de la santé des services sociaux on va
revenir spécifiquement aux deux
fédérations de médecins les négociations
mais cette semaine je suppose que tu as
bonne au quotidien le devoir montre que
vous allez le lire j'imagine
régulièrement de une cette semaine
qui
font état de la pénurie de médecins de
famille une clinique qui ferment au
centre-ville de montréal
c'est souvent les unes des journaux les
manches la santé là ça fait la manchette
tous les jours oui alors pour les quatre
prochaines années vous allez être
confronté à ça est ce que la ministre de
la santé que vous êtes devenu être
capable par exemple de sauver une
clinique qui est l agonie celtique du
devoir qui perd six médecins qui en
avait 25 quelques années il y aurait 5
et à qui on dit d'un côté on peut pas
vous envoyer le médecin et les fameux
prennent les plans de régionaux
d'effectifs médicaux
on n'envoie pas de médecin montréal dont
le site ici fable utile que les pénuries
sont les plus importantes et vous avez
été à mon vieux oui et je connais
montréal très bien j'étais pdg de
lagence de montréal pendant deux ans
la question que vous soulevez c'est une
question extrêmement prioritaires
évidemment il faut que je prenne
connaissance du dossier d'une façon le
qui lui donne justice mais c'est clair
madame tussauds que c'est une grande
priorité d'intervenir à court et à moyen
terme dans ce dossier et j'ajouterai que
différentes stratégies aussi nous avons
besoin des médecins de famille montréal
il faut s'y pencher comme la montérégie
comme les laurentides comme la mauricie
puisque des besoins importants mais il
ya aussi la question du rôle des autres
professionnels qui vont mettre la main à
la pâte davantage le font déjà mais ses
skis et c'est sur quoi il faut miser
parce que devant déléguer à d'autres
professionnels je sais que vous pouvez
avoir en tête les infirmières les
superinfirmières on n'a pas eu de compte
encore pu même lieu à peine de moins
d'un an ou deux ce qui manquait encore
près de 2000 infirmières au québec donc
on va pas inventer du jour au lendemain
la délégation us et cliniques va fermer
en juin elle avait 25 médecins ces
quarante mille d'aussi peut-être des
milliers de patients qui vont rester
orphelin parce que semble-t-il les
règles d'attribution des postes de
médecins en défavorisés
a lancé que vous êtes un gouvernement
qui vous répondent et les régions mais
qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire pour ça
c'est certain même si nous allons nous
pencher sur cette situation due à une
situation particulière à montréal parce
que des médecins qui sont à montréal
voit aussi des travailleurs qui viennent
d'autres régions
alors évidemment il faut voir comment on
en tient compte dans les calculs qui
sont faits pour les prem et s'il ya des
modifications à faire à ce niveau là
nous allons les faire alors on va
essayer de rendre justice qui ait une
équité entre les différentes régions
en tenant compte des spécificités de
montréal par exemple donc une forte
clientèle que nationalement absolue à la
population oui oui à chaque printemps
c'est les jeunes médecins diplômés qui
postulent pour notamment devient médecin
de famille ou médecins spécialistes - au
printemps c'est un cri d'alarmé que la
fédération lançaient des oeufs des
praticiens ils ressentent de poste 65
postes mais le résident se dit que vous
soyez horizons médecins de famille en
moins mais qui s'annonce dans le réseau
dans la région d'abitibi ces 19 postes
sur 22 qui ont pas été comblé à cause
peut-être du manque d'attrait le manque
d'attrait de la médecine familiale
on les a beaucoup critiqué les médecins
de famille ces dernières années et je
pense qu'il faut soutenir nos médecins
de famille parce que vous savez la loi
de 20 ct traite c'est la vivre pour nos
médecins de famille c'est le bâton à
quelque part là loi 20 ou ce qu'on veut
c'est vraiment de la collaboration
notamment avec la fédération des
médecins omnipraticiens mais avec aussi
d'autres associations de médecins et je
pense que avec l'esprit que nous avons
de collaboration et des stratégies
nouvelles
nous espérons évidemment attiré
davantage de médecins de famille je
pense qu'il ya eu des dommages dans ce
sens là avec ce qui a été fait dans les
quatre dernières années alors penser que
la stratégie de forcer les médecins à
travailler plus s'ils avaient plus
d'argent que c'est une mauvaise pratique
je pense que c'est la proche la broche
qui a été problématique c'est sûr que
les médecins ne sont pas seuls dans le
réseau il ya un décloisonnement pratique
qui doit être fait de la modification du
mode de rémunération qui est une clé
importante de ce que nous
faire à l'ensemble des professionnels je
pense aussi madame tussauds non
seulement aux infirmières aux
travailleurs sociaux etc mais aussi aux
ambulanciers au pharmacien lui vraiment
une ensemble de possibilités et il va
falloir vraiment travailler à attirer
davantage de médecins de famille dans
les fonctions dans les po salle à moi je
vais prendre le temps de bien prendre
connaissance du dossier et je serai très
content de revenir à votre émission pour
vous en parler
la promesse de 90 minutes à l'urgence
vient avec le fait qu'il y aura des
médecins de famille dans des cliniques
comme celle qui s'apprête à fermer parce
que les gens vont là l'urgence ils
peuvent plus de leurs cliniques
ils vont à l'urgence ils peuvent pas
avoir accès en gmf
ils vont là l'urgence mais gérer les
fonds de la misère parce qu'ils peuvent
pas embaucher d'infirmières il y en deux
pour une banque delubac de personnel
oui donc est-ce que ça va être oui oui
madame
ça va être la priorité numéro 1 de
renforcer la première ligne est de
travailler à ce que ces situations vous
décrivez diminue de plus en plus qu est
ce que vous souhaitez que le médecin de
famille enregistre plus de patience j'ai
ressorti une promesse du plq du 30 ou
2018 les libéraux promettait d'augmenter
non pas la cible de 85 % mais l'augmenté
quasiment 90% et de sortir les pénalités
de la fameuse loi
oui pour décembre 2009 en décembre 2018
allez vous a piqué les pénalités prévues
par la loi
écoutez moi je sais que je vais vous
dire davantage mais si vous permettez
sait que la clé c'est le changement de
mode de rémunération ça veut dire que il
faut que les médecins de famille puisse
prendre davantage de patients que ces
patients-là n'aillent plus à l'urgence
des problèmes mineurs
et ce mode de rémunération la prise en
charge vont aider le travail interdit ce
jour-là prendre davantage de patients
qui ont des problèmes à nos mineurs mais
si ça va pas se perdre si le moins 200
vols et le tiers des médecins de famille
qui déjà sont payés à la voie lactée à
la capitation un mélange hybride ça se
fait de plus en plus de réchauffement de
médecin pour un cash mais normalement
les libéraux unissait les médecins l'ont
dès le mois de décembre la voir sur
votre dossier la seconde
tu dois être puni ceux qui ont pas 85 %
de patients d'inscrits mois de décembre
est réduit par vous parler peut-être
aussi de l'assiduité
écoutez on va examiner tout ça mais nous
le bâton ce n'est pas notre approche
je vous le dis vraiment très clairement
nous allons aider les médecins de
famille à ce qu'ils aient vraiment de
l'axé adapté donc de voir les patients
davantage d'avoir des plages horaires
est à peu près le livre le matin le
tiers des médecins le fond je pense
qu'il faudrait que tous les médecins de
face à ce moment tout monsieur barrette
parlait déjà de pénalité salariale peut
atteindre jusqu'à 30%
oui c'est plutôt de 6,8 et de 85%
décembre 2002 qu'on peut pas s'écrire
pas de pénalité en décembre 2018 si je
vous suis bien récolter ce n'est pas
notre approche
à ce moment c'est très bien alors ça
c'est pour les médecins de famille vous
arrivez donc en poste avec l'idée de
changer de peau faire de réformes de
structure mais vous comme betty pdg de
l'agent l'a senti que j'étais dans ces
savants ou qu on s'appelait le css avant
soit disparue puis issus des six il y en
a une vingtaine au québec
alors vous avez dit non aux impôts
question de faire des réformes de
structure ni a déjà travers le québec
qui sont essoufflés des primes et années
qui trouvent que le système est
inefficace
entre autres à cause de cette nouvelle
structure qui a été amené par docteur
barrette a centralisé déjà comblé ses
antennes ne sont pas près des gens ayant
des conseils d'administration à des
centaines de kilomètres des patients ça
vous allez vivre avec cette structure
leur nous allons décentralisée pinceaux
alors nous allons faire un exercice de
révision voir comment ça fonctionne
actuellement le réseau de façon plus
approfondie
mais il est certain que nous allons nous
pencher sur ce que vous décrivez et
faire en sorte qu' il ya davantage de
proximité des équipes des conditions de
pratique qu'ils soient meilleurs
le rôle des comités des usagers aussi il
faut le revoir pour qu'ils soient
davantage valorisés et aussi les
conseils d'administration il ya vraiment
comme vous dites une très grande
centralisation
nous allons décentralisée nous
préoccuper des économies face aux
décisions un peu besoin de changer
structure si on s'assure que les
conditions sont bonnes pour nos
intervenants par exemple que des
intervenants n'ont pas à faire des
kilomètres et des kilomètres d'un site à
l'autre
vous savez alors ça il faut voir ces
combats du monde quand on était au
volant de son double et il faut regarder
ces conditions de pratique des choses
très terrain très pratique et très
aidant pour les intervenants quelque
chose de très concret on a tous à
l'esprit les larmes de certains jeunes
infirmières de sherbrooke il ya des
projets pilotes semble-t-il qui devait
réunir en place le ratio infirmières
patient qu'est-ce que vous avez
saucisses une urgence labour vous le
remaniement
oui qu'est ce que vous voulez faire avec
ça écoutez je pense qu'on a reproché
choix d'ajouter des ressources dans les
endroits où est ce que c'est le plus
critique
il ya un ensemble de professionnels
aussi auxquels on peut faire appel par
exemple des infirmières auxiliaires
c'est à dire que 38 % des infirmiers
rusair qui sont à temps plein
actuellement c'est très bord comme tous
devenus et plus de postbank dont on va
le payer ces gens n'osent pas crayencour
espace suffisant pour lui que son
produit infirmières auxiliaires cc faut
regarder vraiment préposés aux
bénéficiaires et posez moi je considère
que c'est plus beau métier doit mal
payés on va valoriser cette fonction est
valorisée dans tous les sens du terme
alors évidemment reprendre un petit peu
de temps pour faire tout ça mais c'est
notre objectif et nous comptons bien le
faire mais monsieur gunther nous permet
oui il répété la promesse de construire
un hôpital de 170 vous allez avoir un
chantier de construction en commençant
oui c'est pas combien de temps lancé la
construction de l'hôpital
on peut appeler ça des passes à
dépeindre marleau du dossier est gardé à
l'hôpital d'auch à vaudreuil au sila qui
est un autre chantier qui va avoir lieu
c'est des besoins évidemment à
populationnelle et on va certainement
travaillait ce dossier là je suis
convient à beaucoup posé la question de
la fameuse entente avec les médecins de
l'attendre rapport en 2019 monde est
arrivé plus tôt
c'est un grand coeur qui est présidente
de poule et pas de confrontation mais
aura pas de miracle a quand même
pourquoi les buts parce que vous voulez
aller chercher un milliard de dollars
quand même ce qu'on veut lancer vraiment
s'asseoir avec la fédération puis on
veut absolument trouver une solution
gagnant gagnant
je pense que vous l'avez mentionné que
la dernière fois j'étais venu il ya des
médecins spécialistes qui nous disent
moi j'aimerais bien mieux avoir de
meilleures conditions de travail
organisation des soins des ressources
davantage du personnel davantage pour
que je puisse travailler davantage alors
il ya vraiment une bonne discussion à
voir avec madame francoeur j'ai posé la
question à votre collègue monsieur
robert jr
mené de l'éducation qu'est ce qu'il fait
à bord mais les de la santé au québec
sur le terrain vingt minutes la santé
est à l'écouté du des citoyens et du
personnel il est va créer les conditions
pour de l'innovation même du sommet de
l'innovation
pratique alors qu'on est on en voit être
capable d'avoir des conditions pour ce
que par exemple chaque québécois un
médecin de famille et qu'il ya des
services de qualité partout dans toutes
les régions avec une couverture complète
écoute on a fait un premier tour
d'horizon
bonne chance merci à l'art chinois